I will briefly speak about what is
um what this hackathon is about why we
chose to focus on the microbiome what
kinds of opportunities I see for
students and researchers as well as
companies that might want to participate
so let's start by briefly talking about
why microbiome I have some stats here on
the slide that basically show that
startups that Focus just on the gut
microbiome for health Clues raised over
1 billion in VC funding over the past
five years this is 2020 and before so
what we see is a tremendous interest in
the space from The Venture Capital
Community and that just gives you a
perspective
on the overall interest in how
microbiome can be involved in health
disease and wellness now we're not going
to focus on disease here but we are
going to talk about Wellness
um so as you can see it's a hugely
growing uh field and Industry you can
see that there are a lot of patent
applications that are being applied for
and this has grown almost I would say
exponentially since the
2010-2011 and down here you can see how
this interest has a practical Direction
so we're not just interested in the
microbiome the basic science of the
microbiome how it works but we're
actually seeing a lot of interest in
trying to apply
these insights and translate them into
some kind of a product or an
intervention so what we decided to do is
kind of take a look at data-driven
Innovation and what we want to provide
uh the community the broader Community
with are data sets that describe real
world studies and experiments uh
intuitive Solutions so you can see what
kinds of things are people building and
what are they doing with this kind of
data and then explain how such data
could be analyzed visualized and
presented in a meaningful way so for
those students and faculty who are
interested we think that this is an
opportunity to innovate solve and
connect innovate by being creative open
and collaborate with others you can come
at these existing solutions that are
being addressed by others with an out of
the box thinking approach you can really
do something novel you will also see
that this is an opportunity to showcase
how you can solve complex problems and
so for a lot of students this is a way
to Showcase their abilities stand out
from the crowd you know really kind of
apply what you have learned what you
know to a new challenge and connecting
is an important factor here as well so
by working with people who are from uh
the business Community from the research
Community from the computer science
Community you will see that this
interdisciplinary aspect is a huge
component of innovation and we hope that
this hackathon could be an opportunity
for you to do just that now this is
going to be a virtual event so you don't
have to be physically at any single
location you can participate from India
from Africa from Brazil from the US
um anywhere in the world really and I
think the benefit of that is because we
can see that these Trends are going to
continue and grow in the future so not
only have we seen work being disrupted
Innovation and collaboration has been
disrupted as well and I think that at
one side kind of disrupts the way things
have been done but it also provides
extreme New Opportunities so if you're
in India you might be thinking yes this
investment might be happening in the U.S
how can I actually be involved but the
truth is that more and more Venture
Capital firms in the U.S are looking
outside of the U.S to find innovation in
the U.S you might be thinking well how
do I do something differently from the
way that it's done here right and this
is an opportunity to find people who
might have completely different ideas
different audiences different targets
uh ultimately this is an opportunity to
build and compete and by building is
very different than doing research right
so we've seen a lot of uh interest in
research problems that result in
academic Publications maybe this is
intellectual property but it is often
not a product and so what we hope to see
out of this event are more ideas that
have practical applications or at least
a direction at that kind of a solution
what kinds of topics are we going to
cover
we're going to focus here on three
different topics that are all extremely
relevant popular and interesting in the
domain of microbiome the first one this
is probably something that the majority
of the people know about and is the most
obvious one is the Obesity and Precision
Nutrition and what that means is that
the gut microbiome has been studied
enough to show that there's a critical
connection between different types of
foods and Lifestyles with obesity and
Precision Nutrition this also has to do
with food being a functional medicine
so that means that some conditions even
though they are early on can become
chronic and very complicated to treat
with drugs with surgery
um you know with these severe
interventions but at an earlier stage
they could really be prevented with
dieting with different types of
functional foods that help the
microbiome be restored and function
properly
the second may be a little bit less
known field of application for the
microbiome is skin aging and beauty and
we'll actually have an innovator herself
and a startup founder herself but also a
researcher speak about what are some of
those Innovative and cutting-edge
applications of the microbiome to the
field of beauty and aging and then the
final one is something that all of us
have gone through in some way and this
is pregnancy and femtech so a lot of the
microbiome Studies have pointed to
different associations between uh you
know different types of pregnancy that
has healthy or more risky outcomes and
so this is a field that definitely has a
lot of impact as well so for obesity and
nutrition we see that the gut microbiome
has been studied for associations
between diet and the microbiome healthy
weight loss risk of diabetes
personalized nutrition plans
recommendations on pre and probiotics as
as well as different types of
sensitivities and you can see that there
are a lot of clinical trials which means
that there's a lot of data sets that are
available to test and identify
interesting insights from these data
sets so we'll introduce those data sets
and we'll also talk about some of the
industry challenges now in the field of
the gut microbiome the obvious challenge
is that there are some established
companies that come out with very
similar tests at pricing that varies
between approximately 60 and 200 or more
than two hundred dollars they use
different techniques
and they provide different types of
insights but all of them claim to be the
best the most advanced the most
comprehensive so the question is which
one is the best the you know most
comprehensive the most insightful and
what are some of those use cases that
could be turned into Innovation that
could kind of change the way that things
are done today the skin and microbiome
uh has a lot of applications from rashes
to acne to wrinkles blemishes longevity
and aging and so since more and more
people are aware of how their skin looks
and what they do to make it look better
this has become already an opportunity
for people to develop new products and
those new products include things you
can buy on Amazon like new biome is a a
type of a company that produces a lotion
that is matching your skin microbiome so
really interesting direct applications
that are already being done in the
industry now the question is how do
these things work and what are some
opportunities to introduce new ideas
into this space
now in the field of femtech there's also
a lot of studies going on for healthy
childbirth immunity and conception
antibiotics diet and activity
reproductive health and there are
already these products being sold on the
market so I think that there's a lot of
interesting associations even in things
like the child's psychology over the
years being influenced by childbirth and
you know the mother's microbiome so
there's a lot of interesting um
ideas here
um and I think that this would be an
opportunity to both learn about what
those things are and try to develop some
Innovative uh product now we are going
to uh try to prepare everyone to focus
on real problems and real solutions that
are possible that are realistic and for
that we're going to bring in experts to
speak about different types of
sequencing Technologies as I mentioned
curated data repositories where you can
actually find some of these studies and
do something with them
people that specialize in business
analysis and framing the problem in
business terms as well as user
experience how do you not only produce
an example but actually turn that into
an experience that somebody can use why
sequencing Technologies well sequencing
technologies have been one of the main
drivers of cost accessibility
and Detail in this field and so uh you
know companies like Illumina and Oxford
nanoport have developed very different
approaches But ultimately now we are in
a race to the bottom of the pricing
scale right so new technologies are
becoming much more useful and affordable
and that is driving accessibility for
these types of Innovations now for all
of these different types of sequencing
there are still challenges associated
with data analysis so we will talk about
how these data are analyzed and these
include multiple all types of omics data
including intuitive and informative
analysis types and that's really where
bioinformatics and multi-omics data
analysis comes in so we'll talk about
how these types of data are analyzed and
integrated
now after we talk about just in general
what is the logic for this kind of
analysis will actually make sure that
everyone has access to easy to use tools
that they can produce insights quickly
and we'll make sure that you have access
to our TBI info platform with these
different types of pipelines that are
available on there already
now in addition to that we'll talk about
non-omix data where to produce a product
you actually have to focus on finding
associations between omics and non-awmix
data such as maybe different types of
you know lifestyle and activity tracking
devices
this is an important topic and we'll
kind of introduce you to how that could
be done and what are some of the
companies that are doing this already
now when we think about this we're going
to look at the business aspect as well
and that means understanding these
industry trends that we just spoke about
but also looking at customers and their
kind of segments or portions of the
customers that might be the best to
focus on and for that we will bring in
investors that will actually speak about
what is working and what is not working
in this microbiome uh you know
Innovative space that startups are
competing for funding it and they will
talk about some previous Investments
that have been made and whether those
have been successful unsuccessful and in
which way now as I mentioned we're not
going to be the only ones talking we're
actually going to bring in uh experts in
the field that have been working for
decades from different aspects including
startup Founders people that specialize
in sequencing Technologies investors
existing companies that kind of deal in
this space
as well as some reach researchers uh
that are exploring different
opportunities with microbiome data as
well now primarily this event is going
to be focused on our partnering
universities and that's why we are
working to um kind of streamline the
pipeline and the main challenge here is
preparing students to be ready to
address some of these uh interesting
topics and challenges early on right so
we don't want to spend a lot of time on
the basics we want to jump in to the
real opportunities that are there now we
have over 10 000 members in this
partnership program and we would love to
see your organization join here as well
the community that we've established has
grown tremendously and so we are really
excited to see a lot of interest in the
space but we also see the need to
continue and train people to be able to
use omics data both for basic and
translational research so with that that
I will pass it on to Dr raghavendran Who
will speak about
um how this is actually going to work